you know women we just have a tendency
towards chaos men have a tendency
towards order
and for whatever reason what I see is
women are much more willing to adopt
absolutely batshit crazy social trends
um so for example
the trans movement is 80 women so a lot
of times we see these men invading
women's spaces but we never talk about
the women invading the men's spaces
because it's mostly women invading the
men's space
um but on national TV let's see what
these super logical chicks are arguing
transgender boys who might not have
their own money to go buy tampons if
they're provided free in the bathroom
it's it's a huge plus men do not
menstruate only women menstrate now you
can call yourself whatever you want
straight but trans men do menstrual
non-binary people operating is not
exclusive yes it's women no it's not yes
it is
if your chromosomes are xx and you're
young you menstruate if you're ex-wife
you don't correct but what about trans
men and non-violence
they're women dressed as men you are not
a man you pretend to be a man and that's
okay that's perfectly fine live your
life tell me what a man is well what's a
man to you you define a man for me you
have chromosomes that have X and Y
that's what a man is so why are we just
looking at the the the the science of
this as a sign when when we've learned
sex and gender identity a two very a
completely different thing they're not
completely they are completely different
completely different words and sex is
what you're born with the sexual
reproductive organs you have gender is
what you identify with well I don't
accept that distinction you have to
argue for it you're just giving a
conclusion you're you're just making it
up
you see him and like this is what I mean
this is traditional masculinity and this
is the problem women have co-signed
these stupid ideas for too long and then
you get these symptoms men that co-sign
them too this is true masculinity
telling the women that they're deluded
this is crazy and
it's unfortunate because a lot of men
will lose their jobs and have the Matrix
come after them simply because they
State their opinion which is much more
likely to be rooted in fact than women
I'll tell you in my lifetime so I'm 26
right and I remember going to college I
was 17 when I went to college this was
like 10 years ago so I remember when
Bruce Jenner got the female courage
award
and that was the first time that really
we saw transgenderism on the world stage
and at this point um I didn't really
like it but I just didn't care do you
know what I mean I was playing
volleyball I was I was doing other stuff
I was busy so I just didn't pay that
close of attention to it I was just like
whatever who cares
but I actually regret not speaking out
about it more because that was the
beginning
of the end of women's sports
you know now it's 10 years later I in my
lifetime I've seen a man compete
in a woman's swimming competition and
take her medal I you know I've also
actually gone to a volleyball tournament
where there's almost an entire group of
men playing
and be reprimanded by that Organization
for talking about it for interviewing
people and asking what they think
um and this is all in my lifetime and
it's so it's so sad to see how like
something starts and how it is now
um you know and I I would argue that
it's a Eugenics movement what you see is
that the typical trans person is
actually an autistic girl
think about that guys
they're sterilizing they're essentially
sterilizing autistic people
by giving them a sense of community and
family and making them think that the
solution to all of their problems
is to become a boy
and then on top of that they're allowing
predatory men into our locker rooms no I
don't want to share a locker room with a
guy no I don't want to compete with a
guy no
um I think I've played volleyball for I
don't know 16 years now I started
playing when I was 10. I cannot compete
with a man I am six foot I am taller
than most men
yet a guy shorter than me can lift more
than me and jump higher than me it
doesn't matter we're built different
we're not the same I can never bench
what a guy benches I cannot do what a
man can do it doesn't matter if I'm a
tomboy it doesn't matter if I'm strong I
cannot do what a man can do and so we
need to stop with this media movement of
turning women into men and men into
women